you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
the government is warned it's falling
behind in its plans to build a british
battery manufacturing industry for a
future of electric cars
the chinese reservoirs producing
artificial snow for the winter olympics
in beijing where the average snowfall is
less than in the uk
koalas are put on australia's endangered
species list after a dramatic decline in
numbers
and we speak to the climate action
network about the latest u.n report
sending a warning that is hard to ignore
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the electric car industry is big
business according to the iea in 2021
electric car sales more than doubled to
6.6 million representing close to 9
of the global car market
but sky news has found that the
government has been privately warned
that it's falling behind in its plans to
build a british battery manufacturing
industry the document sent to the
department for business energy and
industrial strategy says the uk will
need to increase its production of
critical battery ingredients by as much
as 90 times the current level
sky's economics and data editor ed
conway has been taking a look
it looks like a vision of the fossil
fuel past but what they're making in
this refinery is actually one of the
answers to the biggest question of all
how to eliminate carbon emissions and to
save the planet
for here in the humber refinery they
make critical materials that go into
batteries all over the world
we are quite literally in the bowels of
britain's fossil fuel industry there is
soot
caked everywhere the air is thick with a
kind of acrid steam
and it's all coming
from this stuff this
is graphite coke and surprising as this
might sound it is central to resolving
climate change and getting to net zero
why because pretty much every battery
and every electric car in the world
contains that stuff in the anode and
what is that made from
it's made from crude oil
this is one of britain's best kept
industrial secrets one of the most
important links in the global supply
chain
we're the only people in the uk that's
manufacturing and really the only people
at any scale in europe and so you know
really for the uk it's a significant
opportunity we've got one piece of the
supply chain right here around us right
now it all gets exported to the other
side of the world
the graphite made from this north sea
coke is one of a number of essential
materials which are later assembled into
batteries in machines like this
yet for the time being the uk battery
industrialization center a kind of
testing ground is the only place you'll
find them in this country
is this kind of high value manufacturing
when you're talking about batteries um
yes it is so it's a very it's very
skilled it's very capital intensive as
well so to build the factories in the
first place costs billions of pounds and
there's been some recent announcements
in the uk
a couple of giga factories that are
going ahead
but according to private figures
submitted to the uk government even
these gigafactory plans will still leave
the uk dangerously short of what it
needs
at present the uk has about two gigawatt
hours of battery production by 2030 it
is projected to have about 70 but if it
wants to keep the car industry in its
current state and protect jobs it may
need more than double that 175 gigawatt
hours
the leak data also shows the uk's
requirements for lithium cobalt and
graphite for anodes currently the bars
are so small you can barely see them by
2030 they could be 90 times higher a 9
000 increase raising a question where
will it all come from
at the moment most of the world's
lithium comes out of the ground in chile
in australia but there are pilot
projects producing lithium from quarried
stone in cornwall
we think we've cracked it we've made
lithium battery grade lithium carbonate
it's totally a lithium gold rush you
know no other commodity on the planet is
growing by 30 40
per year if you look at the uk we've got
a 96 billion pound automotive industry
and that's transitioning by 2030 to
completely electric vehicles so where
are we going to get all of these
batteries
an unexpected story of batteries and
metals of green power sources made in
fossil fuel plants this
is the story of our future
ed conway sky news
now for some of the day's other climate
news and australia has officially listed
koala bears as an endangered species
across most of its east coast after a
dramatic decline in numbers australia
has lost about 30 percent of its koala
population in the past three years
partly due to large bush fires land
clearing drought and disease
the woodland trust is asking for the
public's help in raising an extra 1
million pounds to fund a project which
will buy and restore a rural site in
devon the charity wants to plant trees
and shrubs and encourage existing ones
to grow and transform the land near limp
stone for rare wildlife
a new multi-billion pound offshore wind
farm development is to be built off the
coast of norfolk the energy secretary
reapproved the plans today after they
were rejected by a high court judge last
year over concerns about the project's
effect on the landscape the vattenfall's
vanguard wind farm which will have up to
158 turbines could help power almost 2
million homes
now this year beijing became the first
city to hold both the olympic games and
the winter olympics but for a city that
gets very little snow there have been
questions about the sustainability
around it being the host of the event
sky's asia correspondent tom cheshire
has been to the main reservoir by her
bow which is being used to produce snow
for the winter olympics in beijing
nearly 50 miles away
welcome to the beijing alps
as you can see and as you'll know if
you've been watching the olympics
there's not much snow
traditionally rather an important
element for winter games
beijing is incredibly dry it gets less
annual snowfall than london so all the
snow at the games is artificial
much of it came from the water in this
reservoir called baijobao
this whole area is as dry as dust but
this reservoir is a frozen oasis in the
mountain desert and the waters
underneath this ice are used to supply
beijing because it has very little but
recently they've been diverted to create
snow for the winter olympics because
otherwise they'd have none
holding a winter olympics in a place
where it doesn't snow using energy
intensive machines like this have led
some to question the events green
credentials these are the most
unsustainable games ever held because
there's so much uh at cost from the
water issues to the
water availability and even
to the native destruction of the local
nato reserve
others have complained about the big air
site in downtown beijing saying it looks
dystopian
that's probably unfair this was once a
huge polluting steelworks now repurposed
into a cleaner residential and
commercial site
the sort of development that would be
applauded in other cities
but the international olympic committee
does understand the impression that bear
mountains give viewers
obviously you know we're in a winter
sport and we have to acknowledge that
what you see on the screen
might be disturbing for some people
um but the reality is that the chinese
are actually
doing and delivering this winter sport
with sustainability in mind in
everything they have done so from really
building the venues or even repurposing
five venues from 2008
to using for the first time ever 100
renewable energy
to using low carbon mobility
climate change means beijing won't be
the last winter olympic city to rely on
fake snow
snow from a reservoir rather than the
sky may become the new normal tom
cheshire sky news beijing
and you can scan the qr code on your
screen right now and listen to this
week's edition of climate cast where we
explore whether climate change is
putting the future of the winter
olympics on thin ice with three-time
olympian leslie mckenna so listen and
subscribe now wherever you get your
podcast from
now on monday nearly 200 nations will
begin virtual meetings ahead of the
latest report from the intergovernmental
panel on climate change that advises
governments around the world it's
expected to warn about critical loss and
damage to biodiversity which will be
hard to ignore according to the climate
action network so let's speak now to dr
stefan singer who's a senior climate
scientist and global energy policy
advisor at the climate action network so
welcome to you
so this is the second of the three-part
ipcc report the first last august was
described by the u.n secretary general
as being a code red for humanity
this one focuses on the impact of
climate change and how we might be able
to adapt to it so what are you expecting
we do expect as international ngos that
this report tells the truth
that science tells us soberly correctly
what is it what is a threat
to ecosystems to nature to forests to
people and what is needed
to address irreversible climate change
which we are seeing increasingly
melting ice
sea level rice
uh burning forests and increased
impacts on defenders of
communities defenders of the environment
poor communities which need
provisions from the rich countries for
adaptation for resilience building and
of course
to provide them with loss and damage for
irreversible changes because they have
no insurance they're poor
and they're the first to be affected
how far can adaptation go in solving
some of the problems associated with
climate change
that's a good question because we do not
know we know certain things can be done
certainly
but we hope it's not just rearranging
deck chairs on the titanic
the ipcc will look into those adaptation
measures which can be done comparably
easily needs money
needs efforts it's governmental will and
that's a key thing but certain things
cannot be adapted to
definitely the irreversible thresholds
once they're overstepped we will never
never ever be able to get back in
including biodiversity loss
um the reversible losses are also um
probably linked to uh melting of full
ice sheets
so that's where we need to address early
mitigation as well this is not what the
report will be talking about it's
another report which comes later but
reducing and eliminating fossil fuel
emissions eliminating greenhouse gas
emissions as soon as possible
coming to 100 renewable energy will
complement and need to complement the
strong
efforts and actions and financing for
adaptation and addressing loss and
damage for the poorest and the most
vulnerable in the world
the first report was pretty hard hitting
do you think it changed people's minds
within governments around the world will
this one make a difference
we don't know the report is not ready
yet we will see i'm working there
i'm the head of delegation of can
international ngos with my colleagues
with my friends with my comrades we work
closely with developing countries work
closely with small island states and we
hope something will come out which is
yeah very likely another
code red
but we hope we will give politicians
business people finance people
the answer to invest rightly in the
future decarbonization to invest into
poor people's resilience building into
poor people's defenses against climate
change some of those impacts are
unavoidable that's why we need
adaptation big adaptation we're far far
away from that one and so far rich
countries have not done the job they
should have been done
to provide the at least at least 100
billion dollar u.s which was agreed
already back in copenhagen 2009
for um poor people's adaptation to
climate change and poor people's help to
mitigate climate change for instance
into renewable energy's energy
efficiency okay rich countries have not
done their job dr stefan singer thanks
very much indeed
thank you
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by climate activist laura young and
michael jacobs professor of political
economy at the university of sheffield
and we'll discuss whether britain's
electric car industry really needs to
step up again
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate activist laura young and
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield michael jacobs
so good evening to both of you
so electric vehicles are a big part of
the government's plan to reach net zero
by 2050 and it's already announced that
the sale of new petrol and diesel cars
will be banned by 2030. however as we
heard earlier in the show the government
has been warned that it's falling behind
in its battery manufacturing industry
but how essential is that to our green
ambitions so michael the government
falling behind on its battery
manufacturing could that jeopardize the
uk's net zero targets
no i don't think so um we are going to
stop all new petrol and diesel cars from
2030
and that will mean a huge increase in
electric vehicles and those electric
vehicles will need batteries but if
they're not those batteries are not
manufactured in the uk that doesn't stop
the manufacturers installing them and
people buying them they will be supplied
from the rest of the world most of the
world's batteries are now produced about
70 percent in asia
some in europe the uk only has
one current uh battery manufacturing
plant the nissan plant in sunderland
there are plans for a few more um but if
they're not produced in the uk that's
not a problem for the net zero target
it's a problem for our economy and it's
our problem for the jobs that could be
created in green industries
this is the crucial point is that when
we go for
ambitious targets as we've got for net
zero we should be trying to maximize the
employment and exporting and industrial
and local regeneration opportunities
that arise from uh making the products
and the and providing the services and
that's where we're falling behind
do you agree with that laura potential
implications as around green jobs but
not necessarily our net zero targets
as michael has said we will find our
electric cars elsewhere but one of my
main concerns when it comes to the uk
and thinking about electric vehicles is
our reliance on using those as one of
the main ways to get to knees you know i
think one of the focuses that we need to
also be looking at is how we're going to
get to net zero through active and
public transport putting some of those
electric batteries into buses and really
investing in public transport
infrastructure as well i think that's
one of the flaws that i've seen is
always trying to think about how we can
get people from petrol cars into
electric cars versus thinking of how we
can get people using a variety of
different types of transport many of
which are better than electric cars
laura isn't one of the problems with
that is that you're trying to say to
people give up some of your freedoms
people like having their cars and the
freedom that it gives them doesn't that
turn people off the greener message if
you say no go and use public transport
instead
i don't think it's taking anything away
from people actually if anything the way
that our public transport is set up just
now it's really inaccessible to many
people whether that's price or whether
that's geography and so actually by
investing in public transport and active
travel we give people more choices i am
an individual who has an electric car
but i would like to use public transport
more but it's just not affordable or
it's just not in the right places i
would also love to use my bike more and
walk more but we just aren't set up for
that and we need to be looking at how we
give people more choices especially in
city centres where public transport
should be easy we see that in examples
like london but also seeing how we can
connect up different areas like rural
areas so that is an option that people
want to go for rather than always having
to opt for their car and michael the
government would say there are various
initiatives to try and improve the green
public transport around the country as
well but do you think the emphasis is
about right as far as
you know individual cars and public
transport is concerned and the whole lot
going green what do you think the
emphasis is about right
we have to do both of those things of
course we have to make the vehicles that
we do have electric and and not just
electric in their own propulsion but
that electricity being produced by
renewable energy sources which is
actually what makes the car green it's
not just the kind of electricity it's
not just having electric uh vehicles but
we also have to do as uh as you said the
the the walking the cycling the public
transport as well but i would emphasize
that this is a in both in both of these
areas this is a huge opportunity for the
uk
uh economy to go green for people to be
employed in green sectors for the jobs
that will be lost because we're not
going to have so much oil and gas
production um uh to be uh to be
recreated in for example making
batteries and i think it is very
disappointing that um after
really more than a decade of knowing
that the electric vehicle revolution was
coming um this was actually first
started under the labor government and i
was part of that process we first
identified the need for electric vehicle
battery
manufacturing plants
um in about 2008
and it's now 2022
and the uk still only has one okay we've
only got plans for a few more you know
there are 12 gigawatt hours of lithium
battery manufacturing plant planned in
the uk by 2025 12.
the germany expects to have 164 gigawatt
hours of plants the u.s okay 91.
okay i'm just going to i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm just gonna stop that's gone
wrong in the way we've been playing okay
sorry to to speed you up there but i
just want to get onto the next subject
have a bit of time for that as well so
let's move on to that shall we because
as we mentioned earlier in the show the
hosts of this year's winter olympics
have called them the greenest games ever
but are winter sports actually
sustainable in a warming climate and as
locations with real snow become scarce
is their future on a slippery slope
michael the first winter olympics to
entire rou rely entirely on artificial
snow do you think the future of winter
games are in jeopardy
i certainly don't think we should ever
be having an olympic games that
requires the so the snow to be
manufactured um this is deeply
unsustainable um and uh this is not a i
think the criticisms that will be made
of china that are being made under the
international olympic committee will
mean that they won't uh be able to do
this again
um but this is going to be a problem for
all winter olympics the snow based um uh
tourism industry particularly in europe
is in decline because there is less snow
it's moving up the mountains away from
the resorts in many cases
which does mean that the future olympic
games will be uh in jeopardy i'm sure um
and this can't be solved simply by
trying to produce a
huge carbon cost uh fake snow so i do
think that there is going to be a
problem in the future
of all the problems however that we face
uh as a result of climate impacts i
don't think not having olympic games is
the greatest of them
although laura obviously that will come
as great sadness to people and and
individuals who enjoy skiing and
snowboarding obviously it's not
everybody it's some people will consider
it a bit of a luxury anyway but they'll
really worry about future holidays as
well is it something that you think we
should be concerned about
i think we should be concerned about
everything that's going to be impacted
by the climate crisis and the one thing
that i am pleased about if i can phrase
it that way is that this is getting
attention and it's raising awareness to
the fact that even something like the
olympics the winter olympics and snow
sports are going to be impacted by
climate change and really i hope it
makes us look at not just snow but
actually the olympics as a whole as a
process as something that happens every
four years how we can make that more
sustainable and really raise awareness
of all the areas that are going to be
impacted by this and even if you don't
ski it's still nice to be able to go out
on a snowy day and see something that
should be natural in many places around
the world and i think this will
hopefully get us moving even quicker
towards the sustainable future that we
need so that we can enjoy skiing on the
slopes so laura do you think this whole
conversation actually is good for
raising awareness then as you're saying
i mean that the fact that people will
think
be surprised perhaps to know that
they're going to be fewer and fewer
possible locations in the future for the
winter olympics they may have to travel
further for
for a winter skiing holiday at least it
raises awareness of the issues
i think it is really important and
actually artificial snow has been used
before in winter olympics not 100 of it
but even as far back as the 1980s we
were using it to top up our winter
olympic sports and i think it's now that
we realize because our awareness has
been raised through many other things
that we are starting to pay attention
and there's been studies done in the
last four years and even some research
that came out just this year looking at
how many previous locations wouldn't be
viable to be used for the winter
olympics because of safety and because
they wouldn't have any snow by 2050 and
even looking as far into the future as
20 80 if the temperatures keep rising at
the way they are going and i think this
is something that has really put
sustainability on center stage looking
at it through a lens of sport and this
is the kind of interdisciplinary
approach that we need to take when it
comes to climate action looking at how
it's going to affect everything and
making people really sit up and realize
that this is going to impact them and
all the things that they enjoy so we
need to get moving okay on that note we
will leave it but laura young and
michael jacobs thank you both very much
indeed for your time
and that's it for me but we'll be back
next time with more climate news every
weekday at 8 30 here on the daily
climate show so thanks for watching i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you